[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous présente jamal magique
mathieu et said on est à la fin des
années 90 dans les quartiers nord de
marseille mais j'ai plombier magie des
plombiers jamal et préparateurs de
commandes saillie temps de faire une
carrière avec son groupe et moi je suis
vendeur de chaussures après le travail
tous les soirs on se rejoint chez meije
aux micocouliers pour manger du kebab ça
à l'époque c'était la mode et regarder
des clips de rap pendant des heures et
des heures
une amitié solide est en train de mettre
tous ses clips
nous on a un petit peu influencé la
culture in american nous influencer le
rap le basket michael jordan djezzy ça
nous a influencés pas sur la notion
bling bling
mais sur cette capacité de partir de
zéro et de construire de grandes choses
on voulait faire la même chose on s'est
dit et pourquoi pas nous pourquoi pas
quatre petits marseillais qui pourrait
le faire qui pourrait le réaliser
tenté par l'aventuré si on se dit ok
mais qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
et là on fait un petit audit d'un côté
il ya les humanistes said
avec son sens de l'émotion sa
sensibilité mais j'ai avec son sens du
partage sa culture de la musique et de
l'autre côté il ya le capitaliste ça
c'est moi j'ai toujours eu des facilités
avec les chiffres sens du business
monter des modèles économiques et
surtout gagner de l'argent avec des
bouts de ficelle et pour nous faire
cohabiter
il fallait bien l'onu chez nous l'onuci
german jamal c'est ce mec qui à chaque
fois qu'il ya un problème d avance la
situation
ce mec que tout le monde aime bien et là
je sais à quoi vous pensez
et ouais évident mais rassurez-vous
jamal est beaucoup plus cool que
barracuda alors avec toutes ses forces
sur la table ont dit qu'est ce qu'on va
faire on va faire comme ce qui nous
inspire on va monter un label on va
produire de la musique et on va faire du
rap en vrai après plusieurs soirées à
discuter sur quel quel serait le nom de
ce label on décide de l'appeler street
skillz nom imprononçable mais qu'on a
quand même choisi street skillz ça
voulait dire technique de rue
savoir-faire urbain en plus
politiquement correct savoir-faire
urbain pourquoi pas ce qu'on voulait
faire les choses à notre manière
garder notre spécificité rester nous
mêmes cet esprit de débrouillardise de
faire beaucoup avec peu
sas qui nous a toujours soutenus et on
voulait toujours gardé l'humain au
centre du jeu alors on se lance et ça
n'a pas été simple
on a commencé par un vinyle l'opération
a avorté par manque de budget on s'est
dit on va revoir les ambitions à la
baisse et on va faire une compilation on
duplique 200 cd dans un graveur de salon
et on va les distribuer de la main à la
main de poche en poche de coffre en
coffre on a vendu les deux sens mais
c'était pas très rentable donc je me dis
va falloir qu'on passe une étape on fait
un petit crédit et on se dit on va
produire une vraie compilation on va
faire comme les autres
on pressent mille cd je me rappellerai
toujours parce que j'avais c'est 1000 cd
dans l'entrée de mon petit studio à
l'époque et à chaque fois que je passais
devant pour entrer ou pour sortir
ils me regardaient et puis me disais
mais qu'est ce qu'on fout là [ __ ]
libère nous libérerons et puis on a dû
aussi apprendre le monde dans
l'entreprise parce que monter un label
c'est bien mais ça n'empêche pas qu'on
doit suivre les règles de la
comptabilité française
donc on a dû apprendre la trésorerie on
connaissait très bien et sait faire à
l'époque et on a fait la connaissance de
bfr on a dû aussi apprendre le langage
des banquiers ce qui n'est pas toujours
compréhensible quand on est quatre
jeunes qui veulent monter un label de
rap
la réaction des x est un peu déroutante
mais on a continué à avancer on a
continué à se tromper à se relever à
faire des erreurs à corriger et à
continuer à avancer pour vendre ses 1000
cd j'ai dû développer ce qu'on appelle
chez nous l'art de la disquette l'art de
la disquette c'est de convaincre les
gens qu'il faille absolument qui
travaille avec toi et cet art de la
disquette j'ai pu la mettre en pratique
deux ans plus tard sur une compilation
nationale j'ai convaincu un partenaire
parisien de nous distribuer dans tous
les magasins on a mis en place des
stratégies qui ont bien marché et on a
réussi à en vendre plus de 15000 je me
rappellerai comme si c'était hier quand
j'ai eu ce chèque de 76 mille euros dans
les mains soixante seize mille euros
[ __ ] et les gars on l'a fait on l'a
fait ça vaut quelque chose là j'ai
compris que ça devenait sérieux et puis
j'ai compris aussi que si on était
capable de produire des disques
on pouvait aussi produire des concerts
des tee-shirts ont peuvent eux aussi
gérer des droits d'auteur gérer des
droits d'image et je me suis dit label
de production
c'est pas mal mais ça manque un peu
d'ambition on va transformer tout ça en
agence de management 360 comme ça on
sera sur tous les revenus afférents un
artiste et puis je me suis aussi dit il
va falloir qu'on change de nom les mecs
street ce qu'ils triment crise triple
crise crise ça le fait pas
non ça ne fait pas si j'arrive plus et
c'est désobligeant je veux qu'on fasse
quelque chose de pro alors on s'est pas
pris la tête
on a appelé notre agence onu pro
seulement pro comme ça au moins c'était
réglé
ah oui
et on appuie aussi cette agence on les
pros parce qu'on voulait ça on voulait
passer de savoir-faire urbain à savoir
faire tout court on voulait sortir de la
case dans laquelle on s'était mis tout
seul alors ça a changé beaucoup de
choses
les gens ont commencé à nous faire
confiance et à croire en nous la
carrière de saïd a commencé à décoller
on a signé notre premier contrat
national
on a commencé à travailler avec des
maisons de disques avec des partenaires
avec des tourneurs on était même
consulté pour du marketing ou de la
promotion et là on s'est dit qu'il
allait se passer quelque chose
on a même des artistes qui sont venus
nous voir pour nous dire [ __ ] vous
êtes bien sympa on aimerait travailler
avec lui et tout s'est accéléré
mais il ya une chose qui n'a pas changé
notre manière de voir
on a toujours gardé l'humain au centre
du jeu peu importe le chèque
l'important c'est qu'il soit dans nos
valeurs et s'il n'est pas dans nos
valeurs quel que soit le montant
ça nous intéresse pas ça prend plus de
temps mais c'est plus pérenne sur la
longueur alors avec les bons partenaires
les succès se sont enchaînés les disques
d'or disque de platine disque de diamant
les olympiens les dom les zéniths les
bercy et on a touché notre rêve du doigt
le plombier est devenu responsable
artistique
le préparateur de commandes est devenu
responsable des relations humaines et
moi le vendeur de chaussures je suis
devenu directeur de rage ans directeur
parce que j'ai toujours eu un ego
surdimensionné et qu'il fallait me
calmer
donc tout se passait bien pour nous
lagence ronronnait on avait ri on avait
réalisé notre rêve est tout à leur salle
un qui disait un truc il faut savoir se
remettre en question dans la vie tout le
temps et saïd sortait d'un succès de son
album et on s'est dit comment va
enchaîner un autre succès parce que ça
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
difficile est la seule manière
d'enchaîner un deuxième succès c'est de
se remettre en question voir se mettre
en danger
alors après une discussion en soir entre
nous quatre
je vous dirais pas que j'ai eu l'idée
parce que les autres vont mal le prendre
mais j'ai dit les gars il faudrait qu'on
écrive une belle histoire
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire d'un
possible et là je dis à saïd il faut que
tu fasses un concert au stade vélodrome
jim était complètement fou jeudi man tu
te rends compte cette histoire
un jeune comorien qui a revendu au plan
d'eau marseillais qui remplit le stade
vélodrome ça c'est inspirant et pense à
tous les petits qui plus derrière nous
et qui ont besoin d'être inspiré la hem
regarde et puis ça a vraiment de la
gueule
au fond ce qui coule j'appelle notre
producteur de spectacles avec qui on
travaille
pierre alexandre géré loupé un ça va
ouais et toit coule dix mois on a une
idée on va faire ça donne droit à l'eau
bien mais tu es complètement malade et
tout mais quand on va faire va perdre de
l'argent et où je dis père je m'en fou
regarde l'histoire qu'on va raconter et
m'a dit t'es vraiment dingue matteo et
c'est pour ça que j'aime travailler avec
toi donc je vous suis et c'est pour ça
qu'on aime travaille avec lui parce
qu'il est aussi dingue que nous alors on
se met au travail
à l'époque on décide quand même de faire
un stade vélodrome sans aucun morceau de
l'album on se dit ah ça y est t'es sûr
et tout une dite inquiète mal je vais
réussir je vais réussir dit ok je te
fais confiance au temps de vie et un
soir il m'appelle il dit bref ce qu on
s'appelle souvent au soir ce que la
journée au travail et me dit j'ai trouvé
concept cet album je vais l'appeler
l'everest
parce que ce stade vélodrome c'est le
sommet que je veux atteindre
et là je dis comme d'hab d'un génie mon
pote ça va marcher
donc il se met à travailler il enchaîne
les morceaux je prépare une bonne petite
stratégie et on sort cet album
alors on démarre doucement parce qu'une
montagne vaut mieux pas sprinter au
début il faut être endurant
on sort cet album et après des heures de
promo de déplacement de trains d'hôtel
de sacrifice de moments loin de chez
nous on se retrouve le 7 octobre 2010
est dans un stade vélodrome rempli à
craquer et là on est ainsi
et là on est dans les loges entre nous
on profite de ce moment c'est pas tous
les jours qu'on fait ça si on est des
marseillais on est là dans les
vestiaires avec le nom des joueurs on
pense à 93 avec des champions tout ça y
est on y est là et d'un coup on est
dérangé par quelqu'un et j'aime pas
quand on est dérangé avec les avant les
concerts j'aime bien qu'on reste entre
nous pour garder l'énergie est là qui
tapent à la porte avec qui je me
retrouve nez à nez
zinédine zidane
vous pouvez imaginer pour quatre gamins
de marseille de se retrouver en face de
zinedine zidane qui vient vous féliciter
dans vos salles vélodrome l'énergie que
ça nous a donné parce que c'est facile
d'aller voir si dans son stade pour le
féliciter mais que zidane vient de
madrid près de l'avion et viennent dans
votre stade pour vous serrer la pince
c'était au delà de toutes nos espérances
alors
alors c'est le moment fatidique j'aï de
monde sur scène gère ce stade comme
comme si l'on faisait tous les vendredis
tout se passe bien le public communie
avec lui et là il se passe quelque chose
une alchimie se met en place certains
d'entre vous il y étaient ils l'ont vécu
et je descends dans la foulée je me dis
il faut que je vive ce moment avec les
gens j'ai besoin de sentir cette énergie
et là je me retrouve à côté de naïma
naïma c'est la petite soeur de saïd
je la connais depuis qu'elle a un an
vous voyez maggie simpson c'est la
version comorienne
et là à côté de moi et d'un coup elle se
met à pleurer je la regarde cinéma
qu'est ce qui se passe
m di matteo il ya mes trois frères sur
scène je vous ai vu grandir
j'étais à côté de vous du premier jour
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
et là je suis submergé par l'émotion et
je me mets à pleurer avec elle elle est
là elle peut l'attester
elle m'a vu pleurer et ce jour là je
comprends qu'on a réalisé quelque chose
qui peut être inspirant et le soir en
rentrant
j'appelle german toujours le soir et je
lui dis man
il faut qu'on raconte notre histoire pas
parce que on est les meilleurs et qu'on
est trop fort et c'est en extérieur mais
parce que quand j'étais petit j'aurais
bien aimé que quelqu'un me raconte cette
histoire ça m'aurait fait aller encore
plus loin
alors je vais pas mentir aux plus jeunes
d'entre nous qui sont là je vais pas
leur dire que ça a été facile
le business c'est pas facile on s'est
cassé la gueule on a perdu de l'argent
on a eu des galères on est tombé 10 fois
nous on s'est relevé onze fois on a été
déterminé on a continué à avancer de
manière pragmatique et en gardant une
bonne humeur légendaire et tout ça grâce
à l'amitié qui nous lie et je vais pas
vous dire que notre amitié elle était
facile qui sont insupportables
ils sont insupportables on sait détester
on s'est engueulés on sait plus parler
mais on sait jamais lâché on sait jamais
trahi on est toujours restés ensemble
dans les eaux et dans les bas et c'est
ce message là que je veux passer aux
plus jeunes d'entre vous et aux moins
jeunes parce qu'il y'a pas d'âge pour
réaliser ses rêves
c'est que si ces quatre gamins que vous
voyez là sont passés de ça à ça c'est
que vraiment tout est possible merci
beaucoup
et comme vous l'aurez compris c'est pas
mon histoire mais notre histoire
donc je vous demande d'accueillir meije
jamal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
mais là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
la scène aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]